today I feel
Qatari
the head of world football on the eve of
the World Cup
today I feel Arab
the first in the Middle East
today I feel African Johnny Infantino
not following his own advice to now
focus on football
today I feel uh gay it was a bizarre at
times rambling starts with tirade
today I feel disabled and it went on
accusing critics of double standards
today I feel
a migrant worker
the FIFA president as the voice of Qatar
dismissing lingering questions over its
suitability
scrutiny that's hypocritical to him has
produced change
but labor abuses and discrimination puts
our fans and the late decision to ban
alcohol sales at stadiums raised a
bigger concern
fans are asking how can qatar's word now
be trusted on things like LGBT rights
and migrant worker rights particularly
after this world cup
when it comes to the security of people
if you spoke about LGBT everyone is
everyone's security is granted
from the highest level of the country
and this is the guarantee that we gave
give and we stick to it
Johnny Infantino spent more than an hour
delivering a lecture taking on the
critics and issuing a strident defense
of Qatar he said Europeans should spend
thousands of years apologizing for the
actions of the past rather than
delivering moral lessons it ensures the
focus at the start of this World Cup is
still very much on all the issues facing
Qatar rather than on the start of the
football itself
is it hypocritical of him to deliver a
moral lecture I found the whole speech
quite astonishing and quite jaw-dropping
and I think there was a big
contradiction between telling
footballers and football teams in the
world not to talk about human rights
issues and then to have extremely long
speech about a whole range of politics
he talks about a huge range of issues
some of which are legitimate talking
about refugees in Europe is a legitimate
question but he is the he is the head of
FIFA and it's FIFA as the responsibility
of this world cup and we wanted to hear
him talk about what he would do
practically to compensate workers and to
ensure equality for LGBT communities you
want to criticize someone come to me
criticize me here I am you can crucify
me
I'm here for that don't criticize Qatar
don't criticize the players don't
criticize anyone
or do we want to continue to divide do
we want to continue to spit on the
others just because they look different
or they feel different the World Cup
that nearly brought down FIFA is finally
ready to begin Johnny Infantino
determined to see Qatar celebrated not
vilified Rob Harris Sky News Doha